mid-sized automotive suppliers slim  scale food producers and call centers  are among the most common employers in  eastern Germany the small and  medium-sized enterprises in the East  aren't as productive as the more  technologically advanced major companies  in the West in the early 1990s companies  in the East produced around seventy  percent of the amount produced in  western Germany and little has changed  since then overall a shrinking number of  people in Germany are employed on a  full-time basis the number of hours  worked by women in the east and west is  more similar now until nineteen ninety  most women in the East had full-time  jobs now they're working fewer hours in  the West more women are joining the  workforce but often only part-time in  both parts of Germany men earn more than  women in the east the average monthly  earnings of women are almost 200 euros  less the men in the West the difference  is more than 800 euros